Here is a view of Xcode
showing our PitchPerfect apt.
I'm going to go over some of
the basic parts of Xcode.
And we'll be diving into
the coat in just a moment.
On the left side,
you can see the navigator panels
starting with the Project Navigator.
On the middle is the content area, and
it's currently showing the settings for
a pitch perfect project.
On the right side,
you have the utility area,
with the inspector panels with a file
inspector panel currently open.
On the bottom, you can see the debug and
console windows.
Unlike other IDEs and
editors you may have used in the past,
Xcode requires only a single click
to select a file or an item.
Starting with a navigator panel on the
left, there are many different ways to
view the files and
other parts of your project.
There are even ways to move through
these panels with just a keyboard.
As an example,
you can use command zero to toggle
the navigator's panel on and off.
If like me, you need to find more
screen space from time to time.
On the right side we have
the inspectors panel and
the number available depends on
the content or items you have selected.
In the case of this project setting we
can see file in quick help inspectors.
As you progress with your app you'll
be able to see other inspectors.
Much like the navigator panels you can
toggle the inspector panels by using
keyboard shortcuts to move through them.
This is especially useful if you're in
need of more space to view your content.
At Udacity we have a saying
that content is king.
And with Xcode that is also true.
The code and even your user interface in
storyboards are always in the center of
view here and
the prime spot in the content editor.
On the bottom right we
have the library and
at the very bottom of the screen you
can see the debug and console panels.
The console panel is where you
see the Hello World printed.
The Exco content editor is where you
going to spend a lot of your time
as an iOS developer.
It can.
Adapt to help you
edit any part of your project.
>From project settings, to code,
to user interface elements.
Knowing that the editor is
contact sensitive can help a lot
when you're looking for how to change
a particular setting in Xcode.
With a Pitch Perfect project, which
is a little blue icon here on the top
of the project navigator we can see
the settings for the entire project.
We can see the version
that iOS is targeting, and
we can see that the interface file
is called Main for Main story board.
We can also use this decide what
orientation to support, and
to launch it.
Here you can see we're supporting
the portrait orientation,
as well as Landscape Left and
Landscape Right.
If we select the AppDelegate Swift file,
we can
see that the Xcode editor panel changes
to let us modify the Swift source code.
You can see that Xcode
automatically highlights the code
to make it easier to read.
Remember that main storyboard selection
back in the project settings?
That's referring to this file,
main.storyboard.
If you select it in a project
navigator with a single click.
The X Code editor changes to show you
the user interface for this application.
You can use two finger pinch to zoom out
of it so you can see the entire thing.
This is the view we're
going to use to set up.
Any UI elements for our IOS apps,
including pitch perfect.
I know it may seem like a lot but
we'll walk you through step by step and
touch every part of Xcode by the time
you've completed this course.